[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انها الساعه 60 برنامج
اخباري خاص ومتنوع وبيقع سريع ومختلف جدا
نحلل الاحداث بابعادها وبعمق وبين العاجل
والمهم نضع امامكم الاهم والصوره الكامله
البدايه من العناوين
بجيش بولادي و ضربات دبلوماسيه الصين تدخل
مرحله التجديد العظيم رسائل تشيجم بينج
لامريكا اوضح
اما ما تولى حوادث اطلاق النار سلاح
قانوني للمكافحه قانون جيرلاند امل
الامريكيين
وفي ملفات الساعه ستون بين الدعم السريع
والتدخل السريع هل يتجاوز البرهان وحمتي
خلافاتهما ويجنبان السودان مواجهه مسلحه
الاحتيال والنصب يزيداني من المشاكل
الاقتصاديه في مصر على طريقه
[موسيقى]
كسر التقاليد هذا هو عنوان الولايه
الثالثه للرئيس الصيني الذي انتخب قبل
ايام رئيسا واسلافه بقوه في السلطه
لفترتين ورغم احكام تشي قبضته في الداخل
الا انه نادرا ما واجه وضعا اكثر اضطرابا
على الساحه الدوليه كما يجري حاليا
استغلت بكينه الوضع لصالحها في اكثر من
مجال وبالتالي باتت خصما لبعض الدول
الغربيه ومنها امريكا بالطبع الصراع
بينهما يشبه مرحله الحرب البارده رغم تعهد
بايدن لالا تكون هناك حرب بارده شديده
كما قلت منذ بدايه ادارتي نسعى للتنافس مع
الصين وليس للصراع لا نسعى الى حرب بارده
جديده
لكن كل المؤشرات تقول العكس فمثلا
استراتيجيه بايدن الاونه القوميه الصادره
في اكتوبر الماضي ترى الصين مصدر تهديدا
اكبر من موسكو للنظام العالمي الحالي
بايضا اذا يتعامل مع الصين كخصم السنين
التي كانت كفيله بتغيير رايه ففي اواخر
التسعينات كان بيضا عضوا بمجلس الشيوخ
الامريكي وكان احد اللاعبين الاساسيين في
الترحيب بالصين في منظمه التجاره العالميه
وقتها لم تكن الصين عدوا هكذا صرح بايدن
بنفسه للصحفيين خلال رحله له الى شنغهاي
عام 2000 السؤال لماذا تغيرت وجهه نظر
بايدن كان الغرب يردد في القرنين الثامن
عشر والتاسع عشر دعوا التنين نائما ربما
كان يعلم ان استيقاظه يعني سيطرته على
العالم وهو ما حدث بالفعل الصين تحولت في
اقل من 70 عاما الى واحده من القوى العظمى
في العالم
اقتصاديا مثلا باتت هي الثانيه بعد
الولايات المتحده والتوقعات ان تكون
الاولى في حلول 2028 صنع في الصين ربما
هذه العباره هي الدليل على نجاح التحول
الصيني والاكيد وانت تشاهد هذه الحلقه
هناك ما يحيط بك مكتوب عليه هذه العباره
هذا الامر تؤكده لغه الارقام عام
1978 قيمه صادرات الصين كانت عشره مليارات
دولار فقط اي اقل من واحد في المئه من حجم
التجاره العالميه ولكن في عام 2019 بلغت
قيمه الصادرات الصينيه للخارج نحو
التريليونين ونصف مليار دولار باتت اكبر
مصدر للسلع في العالم وجاءت شيء ليكمل هذه
السياسه لكن بطموحات مختلفه ليس الهدف فقط
التنميه الاقتصاديه الصافيه بل استعمال
النجاح لاغراض النفوذ السياسي
في العالم
[موسيقى]
تجنيد الامه الصينيه عمليه مع تاريخيه لا
رجعه فيها رساله واضحه اطلقها الرئيس
الصيني في اول خطاب له بعد انتخابه لفتره
ثالثه تصريحات تتزامن مع ضربه دبلوماسيه
غير مباشره من واشنطن قوه الصين
الدبلوماسيه التي ظهرت في توقيع السعوديه
وايران اتفاقا لاستئناف العلاقات ببساطه
صينيه ضربه حدثت واخرى تلوح في الافق بعد
لقاء مرتقب بين بوتين وتشيكي موسكو ينوي
الاخير التواصل مع نظيره الاوكراني للمره
الاولى منذ بدء الحرب بحسب
طرحوا بكين لنفسها كبديلا لهيمنه واشنطن
في المنطقه ليس وليد اليوم في عام 2016
اخبر شيم مسؤولي جامعه الدول العربيه ان
بلاده لن تستخدموا كلا او طنخرط في خلق
مناطق نفوذ اذا وكما قال شي مرحله قادمه
لا رجعه فيها تتوافق مع تحركات داخل الحزب
الحاكم وايضا رسائلها لواشنطن تعيين
رئيسا جديدا للبروسراء وليشنكوفو المدرج
على قائمه العقوبات الامريكيه وزيرا
للدفاع
يسعى لتحويل الجيش الصيني الى جيش فولاذي
والي تنفيذ هذه الخطه رفعت بكين من
ميزانيه الدفاع بنسبه
7.2% خلال العام الجاري
204 224 مليار دولار لكن لا فائده من
تطوير وشراء الاسلحه من دون اداره الجيش
ابي الطريقه الامثل وزير دفاعا جديد كما
ذكرنا مع وجود لجنه مركزيه عسكريه ستكون
مسؤوليتها الاشراف على كل ما يتعلق بالجيش
بافرعه المختلفه بما يضمن امن الصين
القومي على مدار عقد حكمته البلاد لم يعين
رئيس اللجنه وهو تشي نفسه لم يعين نائبا
اول له من خلفيه مدنيه هذا المنصب توه هو
نفسه عام 2010 قبل ان يتراس اللجنه في عام
2012 اي قبل توليه الرئاسه بعدها بعام من
بين مهام اللجنه طبعا قضيه تايوان بكين
صبرها ينفذ تم تعيين وايدونج القائد
السابق للجبهه الشرقيه المواجهه لتايوان
نائبا لرئيس اللجنه سابقه اولى من نوعها
في هذا التعيين الرجل ليس لديه عضويه اي
من لجنتي الحزب سواء العسكريه او المركزيه
اذا خطط الصين كثيره ومنها ما هو في بحر
الصين الجنوبي تمر منه معظم تجاره الصين
ولذلك تعمل بكين بخطه اخرى على زياده
نفوذها وقوتها فيه لكن كيف عبر خطه طويله
الامد بدات منذ نحو عقد وقت تولي شي
الرئاسه عبر سفونها الجارفه للرمال حولت
الصين الشعاب المرجانيه الى جزر اصطناعيات
تستخدم كمواقع عسكريه خطه صينيه شملت ايضا
بناء مواقع قتاليه متقدمه
الموظفي على القوات الامريكيه فثلاثه من
تلك المواقع توجد في جزر سبارتلي التي
شهدت مؤخرا اكثر من حادث بين الجنوبين
وكذلك مواقع في جزر بارسيل اقصى الشمال
ومن اجل ذلك للحفاظ على خطوطها اللوجستيه
مفتوحه مع قواعدها الجزريه النائيه في جزر
بارسيل وجزر سبارتلي طورت بكين التنين
اكبر طائره برمائيه في العالم تقلع وتهبط
على المدارج البريه مثل اي طائره تقليديه
او تنطلق بسلاسه من على المسطحات المائيه
بفضل العوامات المتدليه تحت اجنحتها
[موسيقى]
ولمتابعه هذا الملف ينضم الينا في
الاستوديو الهام لي الكاتب الصحفيه
الصينيه اهلا بك في هذه العقيده الصينيه
الجديده وخاصه في الجانب البحث عن نفوذها
الدولي هناك تحد او رسائل واضحه جدا
للولايات المتحده وعلى عده مستويات والصعد
الم تعد تخشى الصين الان تصعيدا مواجهه مع
الولايات المتحده
نعم اول شيء شكرا جزيلا للاستضافتكم في
الحقيقه يعني لا نقلق بدها سعود لماذا لان
الان موجوده تسعيد او توتر للعلاقات بين
الصين والولايات المتحده منذ عصر رئيس
السابق
وهذا التوتر او هذا تسعيد ليس سبب يعود
الى الجانب الصيني فلو يعود الى السياسات
الاستفزازيه ممكن ان نقول سياسات الهيمنه
من قبل الولايات المتحده الى منطقه اسيا
فيك حتى الى العالم بشكل كامل لذلك يعني
الصين الان في الحقيقه تتخذ ما زالت تتخذ
الاجراءات او السياسات الدفاع
المتواضع او نقول واقعي اول شيء مبدا
الصيني للسياسات الدفاعي هو
مستهدف الى الدفاع عن النفس مهما كانت
للسياده او اراضيها او يعني زي ما لحسنا
في التقرير السابق بان الان يعني هناك
تقويه القدرات الدفاعيه ولكن كل هذه على
الاراضي الصينيه او اغلبيتها على الاعراض
الصينيه بالاضافه الى عدد قليل جدا من
القواعد
اللوجستيه للقوات العسكريه في خارج
الاراضي الصينيه لذلك يعني من الممكن ان
نكون نقول بان ما يسمى بتحديات او تحديد
الصيني هذه مبالغه من قبل الدول العربيه
فقط فعندما نتكلم عن المواجهه بين الصين
والولايات المتحده دائما نتكلم عن
الخط
بجوار الصيني مهما كانت في جزيره تايوان
الصينيه او في بحر الصين الجنوبي لذلك
يعني ما نرى ان هذا التوصيعه للنفوز خاصه
في المجال العسكري بالنسبه للصين ولكن
السبب يعود الى
التحالف العسكري بقياده الولايات المتحده
في منطقه المجاوره للصين نعم ولكن ايضا في
التحركات الدبلوماسيه الاخيره على سبيل
المثال الاتفاق الذي تم بين ايران
والسعوديه بالوساطه الصينيه ايضا هناك هذا
اللقاء المرتقب او المحادثات المرتقبه بين
شيجن بينجلينسكي ايضا يعني بهذا الشكل هل
تريد الصين ان تطرح نفسها كبديل عن
الولايات المتحده
نحن دائما نسمع الى تسريحه من قبل فخامه
رئيس الصين بان العالم او كره الارض كبيره
جدا فكافي للتعايش بين الصين والولايات
المتحده وكافيه للتعايش بين جميع دول
للمجتمع دولي ففي الحقيقه عندما نتكلم عن
التفاق بين ايران والمملكه العربيه
السعوديه
فهذا ليس يعني
النفوس او نقول يعني النفوز الكبيره حتى
يكون الصين بديل للولايات المتحده بالنسبه
الى منطقه الشرق الاوسط ولكن هذا يدل على
ثقه المتبادل بين الصين ودول الشرق الاوسط
اخرى خاصه بين صين
ومملكه العربيه السعوديه وهذا ايضا يعكس
على عدم وجود ثقه متبادله بين هذه الدول
مع الولايات المتحده وبالاضافه لذلك عندما
نتكلم عن السياسات الخارجيه الصينيه في
الحقيقه ان ارى شخصيا سياسات الخارجيه
الصينيه حتى الان ما زال واقعيه ليس يعني
هناك
السياسات فوقه قدرات الصينيه مهما كانت في
الاعمال وساطه الازمات الدوليه او ايضا
لحل المشاكل بان الصين ترى ان المصالح
المشتركه هي على اساس لحل المشاكل والحل
السياسي هو دائما الخيار الوحيد والاول
لحل الازمات مهما كانت للازمه الاوكرانيه
والازمه
الى الجانب الاقتصادي في عجاله يعني هذه
التوقعات التي تتحدث عن ان الصين ستكون
مهيمنه عن الاقتصاد العالمي بحلول 2028
ولكن سنعود الان الى توترات بحر الصين
الجنوبي الصراع مع تايوان ازمه الرقائق
هذه كلها معادله تضع الصين في يعني تحديات
صعبه لتصل الى هذه المرتبه اقتصاديا كيف
هي
لتكون الصين مهيمنه نعم عندما نتكلم عن
الهيمنه الاقتصاديه نتكلم عن دوله قادره
على فرض العقوبات الى كل الدول العالم
نتكلم عن الدوله يمكنه ان يسيطر على
الاقتصاد العالم وخاصه يسيطر على النظام
المالي في العالم وحتى الان لا اعتقد
الصين لديها هذه القدره مثلا يعني هناك
نظام سويفت مسيطره من قبل الدولار
الامريكي وايضا هناك مثلا العقوبات
المفروضه من قبل الولايات المتحده على
الصين على شركات الصينيه وهذا في الحقيقه
يعني عمل عرقله كبيره بالنسبه الى شركات
صينيه مهما كانت شركه رفاوي او كثير من
الشركات الاخرى ففي الحقيقه يعني عندما
نتكلم عن السياسات الاقتصاديه او يعني
التوجه الصيني
العولمه العالميه عولمه الاقتصاديه نتكلم
عن التعاون الوثيقه بين الصين وخاصه عندما
نتكلم عن مبادره الحزام وطريق فاذا تسعى
للحيمنه على الاقتصاد فلماذا طرح هذه
المبادره من اجل الاستفاده المشتركه او
المصالح المشتركه بين صيني ودول عابره على
حزام وطريق وخاصه بنسبه الى دول منطقه
الشرق الاوسط نعم اشكرك جزيلا لك على
وجودك معنا في الاستوديو شكرا لكم
الصحفي الصيني
المعركه بين المؤسسات العسكريه ستعني موت
المدنيه للابد في السودان في الساعه بعد
دقيقه
[موسيقى]
بالوقوف على قضبان محطه القطار عبر سكانه
مدينه بوردوغرافي فرنسا عن احتجاجهم على
استخدام الحكومه الفرنسيه ماده من الدستور
لتمديد قانون رفع سن التقاعد من 62 عاما
الى 64 دون اجراء تصويت برلماني
الاحتجاجات ليست في بوردو فقط بل في معظم
المدن الفرنسيه في العاصمه باريس كما
نتابع تظاهرات لا تهدا منذ قرار الحكومه
يوم امس ما ادى لمواجهه محتدمه مع الشرطه
والغضب وصل لاحزاب المعارضه طبعا والتي
تستعد لتقديم سحب الثقه من الحكومه يبدو
ان الرئيس الفرنسي يواجه اخطر تحدي لسلطته
منذ احتجاجات السترات السفره او اخر عام
يحصد ارواح الاف الامريكيين كل عام وامام
جبروته عجزه مختلف الادارات المتعاقده في
العام الماضي فقط راح ضحيته اكثر من 44
الف امريكي عدو امريكا الاول وصفه بايضا
بالوباء وهو هنا لا يتحدث عن فيروس كورونا
المقصود هو السلاح المنفلت الذي يفتكو
بالامريكيين كل عام ظاهره يزداد ضحاياها
كل عام
150 حوادث اطلاق النار خلال الايام
الاربعه وستين الاولى من العام الجاري
بزياده قدرت باربعين في المئه وللمناسبه
بالمقارنه ذهب ضحيه الارهاب في امريكا ما
يقارب ثلاثه الاف شخص ولمكافحته انفقت
واشنطن اكثر من ثلاثه تريليون دولار خلال
عقدين
فان السلاح المنفلت بقي خارج المكافحه لا
قانون جاد للحد من تجارته وبما ان الشاري
يدفع الثمن فلا تهمه هويته وحتى اذا كان
قاصرا مكافحه الارهاب وتجاره السلاح وجهان
لعمله واحده كلاهما يدر اموالا ضخمه على
الشركات وبلغه الارقام انتجت امريكا خلال
العام الماضي واحدا وسبعين مليون قطعه
السلاح صدرت منها سبعه ملايين ونصف
المليون فقط الى الخارج
65 مليون قطعه منها بقيت في امريكا
والمستفيد 17 الف شركه مصنعه للاسلحه صدور
قرار ايضا يضر باعمالها مخاطره يخشاها اي
رئيس امريكي اما الشارع فيسمي هذه الشركات
يسعى رئيس الامريكي جو بايدن الى فرض
المزيد من الاجراءات الراميه للحد من
حوادث اطلاق النار المنتشره بكثره في
البلاد بايدن وقع على امر تنفيذي قال انه
يهدف الى الحد من عنف السلاح بما في ذلك
التغييرات التي يمكن ان تزيد من عدد مشتري
الاسلحه الذين يخضعون لفحص امني وبحسب نص
الامر التنفيذي فيجب على وزراء العدل
والصحه والتعليم ووزير الامن الداخلي
اتخاذ اجراءات لتنفيذ قانون المجتمعات
الاكثر امنا الذي وقعه بايدن العام الماضي
بالاضافه الى توسيع الحملات الفيدراليه
الحاليه لتعزيز التخزين الامن للاسلحه
الناريه وجدد بايدن دعوته للكونجرس لاتخاذ
اجراءات اضافيه حد من عنف الاسلحه بما في
ذلك عن طريق حظر الاسلحه الهجوميه
واستيراد تقديم سوابق عدليه للاشخاص في
جميع مبيعات الاسلحه
امام الحوادث المرعبه والضغط الشعبي كسرت
اداره بايدن الجمود قانون وصف بالاكثر
الصرامه منذ عقود عده نواب ديمقراطي
وجمهوريون قانون جارلاند نسبه الى وزير
المدعي العام الامريكي الذي اعده وفق
اساسا بسيط اسلحه اقل حوادث اقل البدايه
من سهوله امتلاك السلاح حسب قانون جارلاند
يجبر يجبر الزبون على اثبات الصحيفه
السوابق العدليه بما فيها العنف الاسري
القانون لا يتضمن اجراءات الردعيه فحسب
فهو خصصا 13 مليار دولار لدعم المتضررين
دعم نفسي في المدارس وتعويضا للمراكز
التجاريه القريبه من مواقع الجريمه ما جاء
في القانون لقى ترحيبا من الحزبين الا ان
ماده جدليه لا تزال تصنع الحدث وهي التي
جاءت لتسهيل تطبيق قانون العلم الاحمر او
الرد فلان قانون العلم الاحمر الموجود في
تسعه عشره ولايه يسمح بمصادره الاسلحه من
الاشخاص الذين يظهرون سلوكا عنيفا او حتى
اضطرابات نفسيه مع حرمانهم من شراء اسلحه
جديده
[موسيقى]
من هي خطوه كبيره نحو الامام لكنها غير
كافيه وهكذا وصفها بايضا خاصه وان تجار
السلاح في المقابل قطعوا خطوات اكبر
للالتفاف على القوانين دعونا نلقي نظره
على قطعه سلاح عاديه القوانين تفرض على
المصنع نحت رقم تسلسلي على كل سلاح وهو
امر يسمح للسلطات بتتبع السلاح ومعرفه
المنتج والمالك ايضا الا ان تجار السلاح
ابتدعوا طرقا جديده للتحايل وذلك ببيع قطع
منفصله من السلاح ليتمكن الزبائن بعدها من
تركيبها في البيت وبوسائل بسيطه وهو ما
يجعل السلاح شبحيا وخارج الرقابه شركات
اخرى لجات لحيله اخرى الطباعه الثلاثيه
الابعاد تعرض تعرض مواقع الشركات تصميم
قطع الغيار قبل ان تقتني
الصغار الطابعات ثلاثيه الابعاد من اجل
صناعتها اللغه الارقام تظهر تعقيد الامر
ففي 2016 صادرت امريكا
1700 قطعه سلاح شبحيه لكن هذه الارقام
تضاعفت 12 مره عام 2021 يعني ان الاسلحه
زادت وبكميات ضخمه لكن ماذا بعد الحل
الوحيد يكمن في الزام المصنعين بنحت الرقم
التسلسلي على كل قطعه غيار لكن هذا قانون
لم يحن وقته بعد
[موسيقى]
في السودان اتفاق يتقدم بنسبه تفاهم مرضيه
لاطراف ازمه انتقال السلطه والتوقعات ان
تكون هناك اخيرا حكومه مدنيه قبل نهايه
شهر رمضان اربع نقاط حاسمه في التفاهمات
ابرزها الوصول الى توافق حول مبادئ
الاصلاح الامني والعسكري اجتماعات الناس
تتكثف في الاسبوع المقبل حول القضيتين
المتبقيتين العداله الانتقاليه والامن
العسكري غير ان عقدتين كاملهتين تسيران
بمستقبل البلاد نحو الغموض الاولى تحكمها
بقايا النظام السابق
مشاكل الثاني لمواجهنا برضو تغذيه الصراع
بين الاجهزه العسكريه في السودان
وحنذكر اسم عديل مجموعه علي كارتي تحديدا
مجموعه
تغذي الصراع بين الاجهزه العسكريه وتشغل
في الناس لانها هي بتحاول تستعد لمحاوله
خلق الفوضى داخل الدوله السودانيه
والثانيه خلاف المكون العسكري الذي يتخوف
السودانيون من ان يتحول الى مواجهه انبرت
بها الصدفه واقعه العاب ناريه غطت سماء
وسط الخرطوم قبل اسبوعين وكانت كفيله برفع
درجه تاهب بين قوات الدعم السريع لكن هل
يمكن القول ان المكون المدني موحد هناك
اصطفاف بين مجلس المجلس المركزي وحلفائه
الموقعين على الاتفاق هو اخرى ترى انها
يجب ان توجد ككتله ترفض الاتفاق الايطالي
بالشكل الحالي هذه القوه في تشكيلها
معظمها من النظام السابق والحركات المسلحه
لا تمثل الثقل السياسيه الكبير وبعضها
لولا اتفاقيه سلام جوبا ما كان لها اثر
ما تم الاتفاق عليه بالامس ومن ثم دعا
لاجتماع
عاجل للمجلس المركزي
للحريه والتغيير ولذلك انه
اهميه الاجتماع الامس ايضا بتكمن في انه
لاول مره تم اتفاق على المبادئ والاسس
للاصلاح الامني والعسكري
وداء مضاف لما تم في الاتفاق الايطالي من
الاتفاق على الجيش الواحد وعلى الاصلاح
وعلى الدم
والاجتماع الامس كان اجتماع التميز بروح
وطنيه عاليه
من المكونه العسكري ومن المدنيين
والتطابقه الاراده بين المدنيين
والعسكريين في اجتماع الامس
جاء اعلان رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني
والقائد العام للجيش عبد الفتاح البرهاني
بتكوين قوه تدخل سريع تحت ابره القائد عام
للجيش يؤكد الفجوه والاحتدام لنستمر
وفي المطلحه راعيه لانها تتحصل على
التكنولوجيا الحديثه المستخدمه الان في
العمليات اللي هو الطيران مسير نحن نفتكر
انه الان اصبحنا قادرين اننا نمتلك ناصيه
هذه التقنيه الان لدينا امكانيه جيده من
الطيران المسير اذا كان الاستطلاع او اذا
كان للقتال فنحن نفتكر انه دي خطوه مهمه
ودي
النموذج للوحده نحن في الوحدات السلاح
الاستراتيجي
رساله بدات موجهه لقوات الدعم السريع
بقياده حميدتي كون الجيش يمتلك بالفعل اخر
طراز من المسيرات التركيه في حين فشلت
قوات الدعم السريع في اقتنائها لتعذر
الاتراك عن بيعها الا عبر وزاره الدفاع
السودانيه القوه الضاربه التي تحدث عنها
البرهان ليست جديده واعاده الاعلان عنها
الان
وتبعيتها للقائد العام تاتيان في اطار حسم
دمج قوات الدعم السريع ككتله واحده في
الجيش هذه الخطوه تمثل انتصارا لتيار
الصقور وتجاوزا لمحطه الاختلاف في
التقديرات العسكريه فالبرهان الذي كان
يفضل التهدئه في ملف التعامل مع الدعم
السريع اتوافق اخيرا مع التيار الاخر الذي
يقوده الفريق شمس الدين كباشي الاستغلالي
عامل الوقت مقابل نمو الدعم السريع وتيره
قويه ومتسارعه
اسس الخلاف على الدعم السريع تعود الى
تكوينه في 2014 رفض الجيش وقتها الحاق هذه
القوه الجديده به لنواتها المكونه من
قبليات محدده اختار بالتالي الرئيس
السوداني السابق عمر البشيران يلحق القوات
قوات الدعم السريع بالجهاز الامن
والاستخبارات قبل ان تشتغل بشكل كبير
وتصبح في 2017 قوات انفصاليه منفصله
وامرتها بيد رئيس الجمهوريه تجدد الخلاف
بعد التظاهرات التي دعت للاطاحه بالبشير
في ديسمبر 2018 خاصه بعد الرفض حميتي قائد
الدعم السريع المشاركه في قمع هذه
التظاهرات وبلغ الخلاف ذروته بعد الاطاحه
بالبشير في ابريل 2019 ورفض وقتها الفريق
حمرتي العمل مع رئيس المجلس العسكري
الجديد الفريق عوض بن عوف معجله بانسحاب
الاخير من المشهد
الشوط الثاني من الحكومه الانتقاليه عجل
بتساعد الخلافات مع المكون في المكون
العسكري في المجلس الاعلى للقوات المسلحه
سيضم نحو اربعه عشر شخصا وممثلا واحدا فقط
للدعم السريع ما يعتبره خطوه تمثل احتواء
ناعما لقواته وهو الذي شرع في تكوين
تحالفا يعتمد على اعيان القبائل يلتحم في
نهايه المطاف مع تحالف اخر من القوى
المدنيه
للقوات المسلحه والدعم السريع هم متوازيه
ما في اذا تحولت المعركه لمعركه عسكريه
بمؤسسات عسكريه وانتصر فيها عسكري قتلت
المدنيه الى الابد
[موسيقى]
وتنضم الينا في الاستوديو مديره مكتب
العربيه في السودان الينا يعقوب اهلا
بكلينا اذا هناك الاجتماع يوم الاحد سيضع
اللمسات الاخيره على هذا الاتفاق الايطالي
هل تعتقدين انه سيتم تجاوز النقاط
الخلافيه والنقاط العالقه التي كانت عالقه
طوال الفتره الماضيه قبل شهر رمضان كما
جاء في التصريحات
اهلا بك حنينا سعيدا ان اكون معك اليوم في
استديوهات في دبي هذا الاجتماع هو اجتماع
مهم لانه سيناقش قضايا مهمه تتعلق
بالتواقيت هو اجتماع بين المكون العسكري
والقوى الموقعه على الاتفاق الاطار طبعا
من بينها المجلس المركزي للحريه والتغيير
ولكن هذا الاجتماع لن يحل الخلافات لان
هناك خلافات قائمه ربما نتطرق لها لاحقا
ولكنها لن لكن هذا الاجتماع لن يحل الخلاف
القائم المتمثل بعدم مشاركه احزاب
وتحالفات سياسيه لكنه سيحدد اشياء مهمه من
بينها تشكيل لجنه لصياغه الاتفاق النهائي
هذا الامر الاول الامر الثاني يتعلق هذا
الاجتماع ايضا بتحديد تواقيت لاختيار مجلس
الوزراء المجلس السيادي المجلس التشريعي
وكذلك المجالس العدليه والمفوضيات هذا
يعني ان هناك هياكل للسلطه الانتقاليه من
المفترض ان القوى الموقعه على الاتفاق
الاطاري والمكون العسكري الذي يراسه
البرهان ونئبه محمد حمدان دقلو ان يناقشوا
التواقيت المتعلقه بهذا الامر وان نجحوا
فهذه ايضا خطوه ولكن الاتفاق مازال ينقصه
الكثير ينقصه الكثير وهناك عقده الخلافه
في المكون العسكري وهناك التصريحات ايضا
لخالد عمر يوسف المتحدث باسم العمليه
السياسيه قال انه في حال المواجهه ستموت
المدنيه للابد هل المواجهه مطروحه الان
والى اي مدى
المواجهه تعكسها بعض المظاهر الموجوده
الان في العاصمه الخرطوم قبل نحو ساعه من
الان هناك انتشار عسكري في محيط القصر
الجمهوري هذه الاخبار تمت طبعا كتابتها
وتداولها قد تعطي مؤشرات وتاتي او تاتي
السلطه العسكريه المتمثله في الجيش لنفي
احتماليه المواجهه وهذا هو تصريح اصبح
معتاد رئيس المجلس السيادي ايضا ومن نائبه
بان المواجهه مستبعده ولكن المظاهر في ارض
الواقع لا تشير لذلك ايضا المواجهه صحيح
انها مستبعده من قبل كثيرين لكن هناك ايضا
تحذيرات من المجتمع الدولي لا ترغب بحدوث
هذه المواجهه قد ترين اليوم رئيس مجلس
السياده ونائبه في اجتماع قد ترينهم
يبتسمون مع بعض ولكن هناك ايضا نقاط
خلافيه تظهر اثارها في الشارع ومن بينها
هذه المظاهر العسكريه انا اعتبر انها
مخيفه باعتباري متابعه للشكل العام
لانتشار الشرطه انتشار الجيش هذا الانتشار
الزائد في كثير من المناطق الاستراتيجيه
القصر القياده العامه يشير الى توتر ما
موجود بين الجيش والدعم السريع استعرضنا
الان الخلافات بين المكون العسكري بداخل
هذا المكون العسكري ولكن لو تعطينا النقاط
الابرز الينا في هذا الخلاف بما يتعلق
بالاتفاق الايطالي الان
فيما يتعلق بالاتفاق الايطالي كان هناك
خلاف تم تجاوزه متعلق بالورشه التي من
المقرر ان تعقد يوم الاثنين المقبل
ومتعلقه بالاصلاح الامني والعسكري كانت
هناك خلافات كيف ستعقد هذه الورشه من الذي
سيشارك فيها ماذا ستطرح هل سيتم تنفيذ
توصيتها طبعا المكون العسكري يعتبر ان
قضيه الاصلاح لابد ان تتم منه هو ادرى منه
من القوه المدنيه والقوه المدنيه ترى ان
هناك مساوئ كثيره تحيط بهذه الاجهزه لابد
من ان تتدخل كانت هذه نقطه الخلاف ولكن ان
عقدت الورشه سيتم تجاوزها النقطه الاخرى
المتعلقه بالاتفاق هي عدم مشاركه احزاب
وتحالفات في هذا الاتفاق وهذه الاحزاب
والتحالفات هي مشاركه اليوم في الحكومه
يعني من بينها وزير الماليه وزير الضمان
الاجتماعيه عدد من الوزراء هم
يتبعون لاتفاقيه جوبا هذه هي المعضله
الاساسيه الان في توقيع الاتفاق النهائي
لذلك هذه هي ابرز الخلافات الموجوده الان
فيما يتعلق بهذا الموضوع عوده حمدوك ايضا
تمثل انقساما في الوقت الراهن حادا وظهر
ذلك ايضا في حديث جعفر حسن الذي قال انه
سيتم اختيار سياسي غير حزبي للمرحله
المقبله هذا هو السبب الذي جعل اسم حمدوك
مطروح مره اخرى لانه ليس السياسي ليس حزبي
ولكن ايضا بحسب تواصلنا مع كثير من
القيادات السياسيه هي صحيح تستبعد يعني
حمدوك ولكنها ايضا لم تتفق على اسم وهذا
يدعو بان يكون اسم عبد الله حمدوك مطروح
مره اخرى من جديد جميع الاسماء التي طرحت
هي اسماء سياسيه حزبيه هي اسماء غير مجمع
عليها حتى اسم حمدو غير السياسي وغير
الحزبي غير مجمع عليه ولكن تكون لديه حظوظ
على الاقل يعني ان لم يعني يرغب الكثيرون
بان يكون رئيس وزراء لا توجد تلك العداوه
تجاهه ليس مثل ان يكون ربما حزبيا على
العموم في هذه النقطه في هناك شيء مهم
حمدوك لم يكن حزبي ورات الاحزاب السياسيه
انه فشل الان قد تكون طحين فرصه بان يكون
هناك رئيس وزراء حزبي ربما ينجح هذه هي
النقاشات التي تدور الان اشكرك على وجودك
معنا يعقوب كنت معنا مديره المكتب العربيه
في السودان شكرا لك
تبرد الاسفل تجربه جديده بمنتجات محليه
الصنع في السعوديه سناخذكم في رحله عبر
الواقع المعزز في الساعه بعد دقيقه
[موسيقى]
وجهه
للسياحه العالميه مشروع البحر الاحمر يدخل
ضمن افضل 50 مكانا وجهه سياحيه في العالم
لعام 2003
هذا ما اعلنت عنه مجله التايم الامريكيه
العام الحالي سيشهد انجاز المرحله الاولى
من المشروع الذي يضم اكثر محميه يتم
تشغيلها بالطاقه المتجدده بنسبه 100%
وتهدف السعوديه من خلال هذا المشروع الى
جذب 100 مليون زائر سنويا بحلول عام 2000
التطور التكنولوجي وثوره المعلومات الى ان
يكون العالم قريه واحده امرا طبعا له
ايجابيات كثيره لكن السلبيات موجوده ايضا
عمليه النص والاحتيال الالكتروني
الجريمه الالكترونيه كانت ذات يوم موضوعا
رائعا لاحدث الافلام في التسعينيات كان
الامر خياليا الان مات واقعا في كل العالم
وفي العالم العربي تنتشر هذه الظاهره
وبقوه
137 الف مواطنا عربي يقومون يوميا بزياره
مواقع الاحتيال المالي هذا الامر اتضح
بشكل جلي في مصر خلال الايام الماضيه
واحده من اكبر عمليات النصب والاحتيال في
تاريخ مصر بالسنوات الاخيره
المجتمع المصري اصلا من بعد عام 2011 وهو
يشهد تزايدا في جرائم النصب والاحتيال
احدى الدراسات التي اجريت في الفتره من
2011 الى 2018 اظهرت تعرض
51.7% من النسبه الاجماليه لعينه الدراسه
الى جرائم مرتبطه بالاموال والائتمان
السنين تمر وتزداد معها طرق الاحتيال
والنصب بفعل التطور التكنولوجي بالطبع
اخرها هذه العمليات كان ما حدث بدايه
الشهر الجاري منصه استثمار الكترونيه
حديثه تدعى هودج بول للاستثمار والارباح
تصنف نفسها على انها متخصصه في تعدين
البيتكوين وتقديم خدمات التعدين السحابي
جمعت المنصه من ست الى سبعه مليارات جنيه
مصري من نحو 600 الف مشترك الذين سعوا
للكسب السريع رغم ان الاستثمار في العملات
الرقميه اصلا غير مشروع وف قا للقانون
المصري والنتيجه الشركه محتاله سرقت
الاموال نعم قبضت السلطات المصريه على
مسؤولين في الشركه لكن هل يعود ذلك بفائده
على من تم الاحتيال عليهم الاجابه محزنه
لا
فضلت بقى اتابع نظامهم شغالين ايه
وبيعملوا ايه والكلام دوت
لقيتهم ان هم موثقين
قال لك احنا موثقين تبع الحكومه المصريه
وعاملين عقد مع شركه فودافون وده اللي
خلانا ان احنا نبقى واثقين يعني دخل لنا
ان في نسبه ثقه
ان احنا نخش نشترك في الكلام دوت اه دخلت
ناس زمايلي دخلت فيها انا الزمالك
كلما مرت البلدان بمشاكل اقتصاديه كبرى
واوضاعا اجتماعيه صعبه زادت عمليات
الاحتيال وهنا استغلت شركه هوتشفول الامر
مستعينا بنموذج يدعى سلسله المصطلح
ظهر في كاليفورنيا عام 1920 ويقوم على
استغلال بريق الثراء السريع على العقول من
اجل استدراج الاشخاص للوقوع في الفخ
المنفذ كان الايطاليه تشارلز لكن في
الولايات المتحده تحديدا كاليفورنيا نظام
هرمي او تسويق شبكي والفكره بسيطه يدعوا
اموالهم وكسب ارباح كبيره خلال فتره محدده
دون التعرض لاي مخاطر استثماريه
اسس شركه تقوم على تبادل الطوابع البريديه
من مختلف الدول واستبدالها في امريكا
لتحقيق هامش الربح طور بونزي مخططه
واستدرج مستثمرين وشجعهم على ايداع
اموالهم ليحقق ارباحا وصلت الى
250 الف دولار يوميا قبل اعتقاله
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
كيف تعمل اذا ماء فكره وكيف يربح البعض
اموالا في البدايه الامر لا يتم من خلال
ارباح مشاريع استثماريه بل عبر الدفع
فوائد للمستثمرين الاقدم من اموال
المدخرين الجدد هذا يساهم في بناء الثقه
بالطبع التي تكون اول خطواتها هي الوثائق
حيث يتم اهام المدخرين بوثائق تكاد تكون
حقيقيه في حاله هوتش بول في مصر مثلا
التطبيق له رخصه رخصه سجل تجاري مصري لكن
مسؤولا مسؤولا بوزاره التموين والتجاره
الداخليه اكد ان هذه الاوراق ليست ترخيصا
بل مجرد قيد لعلامه تجاريه ولا تخول
لحاملها الترخيص باي نشاط الا بعد اتمام
اوراق ترخيصه من جميع الجهات المعنيه
عموما تستمر هذه الحلقه على هذا النحو
اموال مدعه تذهب للمودعين الجدد وبعدها
يتمكن من تحقيق ارباح بقيمه معينه يقوم
بسحبها ثم يختفي والكثيرون على مدار سنوات
استفادوا من فكره المحتال الايطالي فانسي
[موسيقى]
في تطوير مستمر لرخاء ونمطي حياه يناسب
تطلعات المملكه وساكنيها مشروع جديد في
السعوديه يضمن مستوى البنيه التحتيه
المثاليه
وبعنصورها الاهم الطرق او تجربه من نوعها
في البلاد لتبريد الاسفلت باستخدام تقنيه
جديده قوامها مواد محليه الصنع
وللمساله ابعد من الابتكار بالتعامل مع
تحديات الحياه في مناخ صحراويا حار
بردوا هذه التجربه يعود الى امتصاص الطرق
لاشعه الشمس نحن في احد ايام الصيف ذروه
درجات الحراره تنعكس على الطرق التي تمتص
حتى 70 درجه مئويه ولو كانت هذه الطرق
المعتاده لا اطلقت ما تخزنها من حراره كما
هو الحال دائما في ساعات الليل
لكن التكنولوجيا الجديده تعدنا بليال
صيفيه اكثر اعتدالا خاصه مع اقتران الخطوه
باخرى تقتضي طلاء المباني السكنيه
والتجاريه بمواد محدده تخفف من امتصاصها
لاشعه الشمس ونتحدث عن استهلاك اقل الطاقه
وخفض لتلوث الهواء المكسبان الاهم في اطار
سلسله مبادرات حكوميه لتحسين نوعيه الحياه
والضمانات تجلت بعد اختبارها في موقعين
رئيسيين في العاصمه السعوديه الرياض لكن
التنفيذ الفعلي سيبدا من محطات الحافلات
والمترو الطرق السكنيه ومناطق المشاه سكان
السعوديه موعودون بالمزيد خاصه مع افتتاح
الهيئه العمل الطرق مؤخرا مختبرا مركزيا
يجري دراسات لتحسين تجربه مستخدم الطرق
وصلنا بذلك مشاهدينا الى نهايه ملفاتنا
لليوم وتتابعنا في الساعه ستون يوم غد
نتنياهو وحكومته يقودان اسرائيل لحافه
الحرب الاهليه والشارع مشتعل في ملعب
الذكاء الاصطناعي من المنتصر امريكا ام
الصين
[موسيقى]